we will know about the the psychopaths
in hands killer instinct their their
finely tuned vulnerability antennae but
it may surprise you to know that there
are some situations in which psychopaths
are actually more adept at saving lives
than they are at taking them so let me
give you an example of what I mean by
that okay imagine you've got a train and
it's hurtling down a track in its path
five people are trapped on the line and
cannot escape fortunately you can flick
a switch which diverts the Train down a
fork in that track away from those five
people but at a price there is another
person trapped down that fork and the
Train will kill them instead question
should you flick the switch now most
people have little trouble deciding what
to do under those circumstances though
the the thought of flicking the switch
isn't exactly a nice one the utilitarian
choice as it were killing just the one
person instead of the five represents
the least worst option okay but now let
me give you a variation you've got a
train speeding out of control down a
track and it's going to plow into five
people on the line but this time you are
standing behind a very large stranger on
a footbridge above that track the only
way to save the people is to heave the
stranger over he will fall to a certain
death but his considerable bulk will
block the Train saving five lives
now we've got what we might call a real
dilemma on our hands okay
while the scoring lives is precisely the
same as in the first scenario five to
one one choice of action appears far
trickier now why should that be well the
reason it turns out all boils down to
temperature okay case one represents
what we might call an impersonal dilemma
it involves those areas of the brain the
prefrontal cortex the posterior parietal
cortex in particular the anterior para
cingulate cortex a temporal Pole and the
superior temporal sulcus bit of
neuroanatomy for you they're primarily
responsible for what we call cold
empathy for reasoning and rational
thought
case two on the other hand represents
what we might call a personal dilemma it
involves the emotion center of the brain
known as the amygdala the circuitry of
hot empathy what we might call the
feeling of feeling one another person is
feeling now psychopaths just like most
normal members of the population have no
trouble at all with case one they flick
the switch in the train diverse
accordingly killing just the one person
instead of the five but this is where
the plot thickens quite unlike normal
members of the population psychopaths
also experienced little difficulty with
case two Psychopaths without a moment's
hesitation are perfectly willing to
chuck the fat guy over the rails if
that's what the doctor orders now
moreover this difference in behavior has
a distinct neural signature the pattern
of brain activation in both normal
people and Psychopaths is identical on
the presentation of the impersonal moral
dilemma but radically different when
things start to get a bit more personal
imagine that I were to hook you up to a
brain scanner a functional magnetic
resonance imaging machine and were to
present you with those two dilemmas okay
what would I observe as you went about
trying to solve them well at the precise
moment that
nature of the dilemma switches from
impersonal to personal I would see the
emotion center of your brain your
amygdala and related brain circuits the
the medial orbitofrontal cortex for
example light up like a pinball machine
I would witness the the moment in other
words when emotion puts its money in the
slot but in Psychopaths I would see
precisely nothing and the passage from
impersonal to personal would slip by
unnoticed because that emotion
neighbourhood of their bled brains that
emotional zipcode has a neural curfew
and that's why they're perfectly happy
to chuck that fat guy over the side
without even bang and I